yeah because the pockets I was talking
to someone they asked what makes your
pot do you why do you listen to men and
I said it's something with you Howard
Stern when you guys get big guests in
it's just like you can tell like you've
X some huge gassy on where you're not
like it's not like a fanboy thing and
it's just like a regular combo
you know yeah I think not that that I
would ask him that I want to know about
it's not you know it's not like a Jimmy
Kimmel train yeah it's a real art we're
really good yeah well fundamentally like
I rely like to start in like the lyric
DiCaprio and Brad Pitt even though it
wasn't in your studio right he did it
like at a prayer was know yeah was that
they done an event at the arc wide it
would like in the back yeah but this why
it worked is Brad Pitt's a fan
oh yeah Aaron yeah so you could tell it
made the cap real kind of like oh cool
you know he is right right there's this
cool that's war the only way it would
work near podcaster he's like he was
like he loves my show Maron man and he'd
watched it like two or three times all
of it over and over again when he was
trying to get sober and [ __ ] like he
likes seeing how he liked the way I was
so aggravated about everything so he's a
fan of the like my short fuse and
everything which was fortunate because
the my machine kept [ __ ] hot during
the interview and I'm dealing with
Leonardo and Brad and I knew the only
way will work I knew I couldn't do what
I do usually no way but if something
happened between us it would be great
and now the Sun I'm getting a buzz so
I'm starting to freak out about the
machine you can tell you a little like
yeah I'm like I'm sorry and I'm trying
to fix it whatever and then towards the
end like I just was oh my god damn it
and piss just like there it is
it was like so thrilled to see me lose
my [ __ ] for real yeah yeah Brad sets the
tone cuz he's like I love man yeah i
watch all of them I've milked it a
little bin DiCaprio's like you know then
he's like oh cool man yeah and there's
like a regular combo but over time like
I think of what happened at the
beginning was I really think that the
first like hundred episodes or so or
just me having famous people over to
talk about my problems and I think that
did Obama come to your garage yeah I did
yeah came to the garage I did did they
have security come no he just came over
in a rental
oh did the security people
yeah man a couple weeks ahead of time
really yeah they and I was in Hawaii I
was on vacation which I wasn't gonna
change even for the [ __ ] president oh
it was so funny you should the episode
to really listen to is the point after
that called the president was here which
is me and my producer Brendan talking
about what we went through to have the
president and how crazy I was because I
had had this vacation booked you know
and the president thing happened out of
nowhere like we'd heard a year or two
before that he was interested someone on
his staff liked and I'm like yeah right
so then all of a sudden it gets booked
and it's like a big deal but it's like
right of like my vacation and I was sort
of like I'm not gonna cancel my vacation
no but but Brendan was like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's just of all time yeah I'm
like am I gonna lose my points I was
really hung up I'm losing the points
what do you need a friend to actually
take a flat hand and slap your face
before they for us you know what
bothered me about the this great podcast
what bothered me is you had to submit
questions to them to okay right no like
I thought you said you there were
certain things you couldn't bring up no
no they were what I off on them yeah it
was we didn't have to submit that was
the weird amazing thing about him there
was no submission of questions and there
was no and they didn't even want final
edit they they sort of trusted him and
they trusted me what I had to do was
like how do I do the kind of interview
that I do know so it was up to me to
stay away from politics as much as I
could because I think that was not I
didn't that was not what I do to want
the politician yeah because then you're
gonna just get this guy who's gonna do
that yeah and you're gonna get in the
weeds and it's gonna get boring so like
it was I had to create questions that
would engage him personally about him
but you know there was [ __ ] that had to
be covered I mean but you know some of
that crazy [ __ ] just shot you
know five or six black people in that
church you know days before yeah there
was some stuff coming up on in the
Supreme Court that needed attention so
because my producers are [ __ ] genius
and you know politically adept
much more than me we're able to
structure the beginning of the show
around the current things that we're
going to be unfolding and then get into
the bulk of the interview but also I
just had an hour so it's really how do I
do what I do not like I didn't have to
give them anything
Wow and yeah two weeks before they send
Secret Service guys over to figure out
how they're gonna secure the perimeter
what the guys on the roof and show that
was the funny thing is like cuz Brendan
my producer fool out to deal with the
closet Hawaii and you know they're
trying to figure out where to put the
snipers right so so Brendan's in the
garage and they got the guys up top you
know jump in there like up here and
they're jumping on it Brendan said the
ceiling was coming in and he's like not
good not good please and not up there
calm believe so eventually we had to ask
my neighbor if we could put snipers on
his roof Wow
and he was thrilled he's retired it was
exciting he's of course yeah so that day
there's like a dozen Secret Service
there's about a dozen LAPD and then like
after everyone's there the two snipers
show up you know they're in uniform and
they're just like they just got their
guns with him stone-cold killer yeah and
they just walk up when I was like use
the bathroom like yeah yeah it was like
intense man and then they just go but
they take the taxpayer about two million
dollars just you yeah yeah yeah but the
but you know in to my credit or to their
credit he was staying in Beverly Hills
that's easy he could have stopped
traffic all the way through if they
drove the motorcade but he flew the
[ __ ] helicopter we did to the Rose
Bowl oh five minutes from my house so I
come on my deck and the Secret Service
guy says we'll give you a heads-up when
these twenty minutes out and then they
see the Ospreys and Air Force two or
whatever it is in the sky I'm gonna see
he's close he's right coming to see you
nervous mark yeah sure I was nervous
because it up ya know like I was sitting
around my house going what the [ __ ] do i
do what do I wear the president's coming
I'm like [ __ ] it I wear what I wear and
you wear my never thought about that
before what I do I wore my shirt I sat
around just me and Brendan in the house
you know see so you could service out
there there's all set up everyone's all
set up and I'm just playing my guitar
I've been mad even if you're in a tuxedo
yeah right whatever change you're like I
spot
he showed up and what was that he came
out well the driveway was tented you
know and the they cleared the road so
the motorcade come and all these cars
are going by and then he stopped and
there's like a dozen people coming up
the grunt drive I was told to stand in
from the garage ingredient and there's
all these people like you know his staff
you have we had to set up five listening
stations they were gonna record it out
on the deck that the White House
photographer and literally they're all
these people coming through the gate and
I don't see him and the others I know
what hand goes up he goes mark and
there's like there's the president right
him and right away he walks up he's like
we're gonna have a good time I'm like I
don't know I don't know man I don't know
so it's hit or miss it's yes but so he
was very boring nervous that stuff sorry
too much just in my mind like a very
nice guy
earnest guy a great show it was good it
was good we leave it up there it's
evergreen you know what my favorite one
is I'm the fan boy first I cannot get a
copy right but the one where you have on
the Argos Hamilton oh yeah when he goes
deep in the comment I love the comedies
you know I don't wait to do that dude I
don't wait years to do is an issue right
yeah he wouldn't do it and with mitzi or
i oh really
uh-huh why out of respect oh I
appreciate that
yes fastly she is a class act always
yeah it's definitely something yeah he's
a class act it was good been him long
you guys go through the old comic store
days I'd loved it yeah I did you have
Mitzi's license I do I have I do ever
driver's license okay I'll get on the
floor now but you showed Argus here the
hell'd you get that sure Letterman -
he's like I think a crimes been
committed
yeah but I'll give that it's like what a
character Jesus Christ I don't know like
you know it's like you when you see him
at the story like he's his face is kind
of blurry but it's like that in a day
time - yeah it's like it's like that's a
regular picture
Bobby Lee when he was all full of hope
and excitement
youie before it all went terribly
so I did my uh I just saw him on stage
at the life after he absolutely murdered
Bobby oh my he's good he's back on top
of it yeah yeah but yeah I've been very
diligent about chronicling the history
of the store with people I can do it
with yeah that's great I like you know
Tom's reason was another one I love Tom
to as Robin flour
yeah yeah and he talks about it and it
does a one-man show about it does any
basis wife Frank's Paul bearer's Paul
bearer's it was a he prides himself on
being the guy that Frank never yelled at
you had Leno on - yeah that without all
the guys a little difficult Jimmy Walker
was great at LeBeau on and schubert but
that's a different generation from the
old-timers I had Richard Lewis Billy
braver up yeah yeah we did a Brian I did
a show together in Vegas huh
and we were gonna book our own openers
they all know they eat the Orleans books
at Stone openers we have a guy he's been
doing for 40 years yeah just I'm doing a
walk in it's Jimmy Walker I don't know
who he is right I have no idea who is
and Ray's delivery so he's not really
speaking with us at all and then his
mind it boy Chandler comes up and goes
uh Jimmy Jimmy like to meet you guys so
mean by like okay we're the headliner
sold-out show so like okay cool walked
up he won't blink it's an Angus I've
been doing comedy over 50 years they
never heard of you - I never heard of
you guys and they tell me your names and
I went he did this longest thing I ever
heard he goes and I was like and then he
got a cell phone was intended to call
like Jay Leno and Letterman he was
actually very funny laughable for that I
don't know him I was like I was like
what the [ __ ] wrong this dude yeah he
was huge huge huge he was the biggest
star in the world that's what people
tell me I died it was a yeah dynomite
and a good actor man and and and could
in that show it's a crazy story that's a
crazy podcast to talk to him yeah he
still like up until I probably a few
years ago he used his I have a
hanging at the store asking for jokes he
paid for jokes
Oh Stella yeah to write juggle turn our
show you know this is 219 this is last
year he was a if you want if you want to
sign 8 by 10 get him in the back if you
want my CD get in the back my Jesus What
did he say to you when you went to go
did he sell any Brendon when you talk in
the crowd when he was like that's my
time
enjoy headliners listen if you want a CD
when I sign 8 by 10 and our Catholic
[ __ ] is it 1980 went to shake your hold
and I went I went to great set you know
legend yours don't touch me brother
don't touch him I went oh ok dude yeah
alright man he's crazy
that's a roast him a little bit you know
I felt bad cuz I found out after what a
legend he was he's a little out of his
mind
so whoever said there's one notice right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]